I can hack into your firebase app in
about 10 seconds then steal and delete
all your data assuming you fail to set
up back-end security rules allow me to
show you all I have to do is pull up an
app and go into the chrome developer
tools under the network tab then find a
request coming from firebase open up the
headers and find the corresponding
project ID from there I can just go to
the command line and run a curl delete
request to the firebase REST API and
start wiping out this app's database if
you deploy a firebase app without
backend rules anybody can do this to
your app as well today I'm going to show
you how to keep your firestore database
secure by writing expressive
easy-to-understand back-end security
rules if you're new here like and
subscribe and grab the source code from
angular firebase comm to get started
you'll want to go to the firestore
database and then open up the rules tab
rules are defined in their own special
language that somewhat resembles
JavaScript currently the arrows pointing
to the root of our database and all of
our rules logic will be defined inside
this block then we use the match keyword
to point two paths in our database where
we want to apply rules in this case
we're using that equals star star to
match every single document in the
database then we use the allow keyword
followed by the operation that we want
to set a rule for in this case reader
right if we leave it blank it's going to
allow those operations or we can write
an expression that returns true or false
to apply some actual rule logic to this
route for example if we wanted to
completely lock down all documents we
could say if false and then nobody could
read or write from the client-side if I
try to query a collection from my
front-end app I'm going to get an error
in the browser console so cool now our
apps 100% secure but that's a little too
secure now we're going to write some
rules that perform logic based on user
authentication the underlying data the
incoming request time etc first let's
look at the various types of requests
that we can lock down first we have get
which would apply to reading a specific
document then list would apply to a
collection query so those are our read
rules then our write rules we have
create which applies to creating new
data update for modifying existing data
and delete for removing data in addition
we could say allow read which would just
combine getting lists or we could also
say allow right which would can buy and
create update delete into a single rule
so that's how we scoped rules to
specific operations now I want to show
you how to point to the actual data that
we want to apply these rules to the
first thing to make note of is the equal
star star that special syntax is going
to tell your rules to cascade down to
all sub collections and anything nested
under that path that's useful when you
have a rule that's applied to many
different collections such as verifying
a user is authenticated you can also
make your rules very specific for
example we can point to a specific
document using that document ID all you
have to do is hard code it directly into
the path and then write the
corresponding rules that can be useful
sometimes but the single most useful
matcher is the wild-card ID instead of
hard-coding the ID we just add brackets
with a variable name that we can
evaluate as the ID at runtime by setting
product ID right here we can use that as
a variable that represents the document
ID then we can evaluate that ID in the
actual allow statement which will see an
action here throughout the lesson and
the wild-card is by far the most common
matcher that you're going to be using
throughout your back-end rules I'd also
like to point out that your rules are
secure by default so unless you
explicitly allow an operation it's going
to be blocked by firestore and my demo
here I'm allowing the user to read the
documents but only delete a document if
they are logged in we can figure that
out by looking at the request object
that is built into the rules environment
the request object is very important and
for one it gives us information about
the current user to simply see if the
users logged in we can see if the
request off does not equal null so
that's pretty cool but the thing I don't
like about it is that it doesn't read
very well that brings me to my favorite
part of firestore rules and that's the
ability to write your own custom
functions functions allow us to
repurpose our rules in a way that's dry
and readable so instead of writing if
request auth does not equal null a whole
bunch of times I'm going to write a
function called is signed in the
function will just return the request
auth does not
a null statement then we can replace it
on the allow line and now it just reads
like a plain English sentence that
anybody can understand allow delete if
signed in pretty simple my goal from
here on out is to give you a bunch of
helper functions that you can easily
reuse in your own project the next thing
we might want to do is determine whether
or not a user is the owner of a certain
document a good example might be a user
profile where all users can read other
users profiles but only the owner can
write to it so here we're matching the
users user ID document and allowing read
if they're signed in but only allowing
write if they're the owner user and
notice how we're passing the wild card
variable to the argument in our function
for this to work it's important that the
document ID matches the user ID and if
you've seen my authentication tutorials
you'll know how to do that then when
defining this function all we have to do
is look at the auth user ID on the
request and compare it to the user ID on
that document that we passed as the
argument if the IDS are the same then we
know that the current user is the owner
of this document and we can actually get
a lot more sophisticated let's say we
want to determine whether or not a user
has a verified email I'm going to use an
and statement to chain another function
to our rule with an and statement both
functions will need to return true for
this rule to pass you can also change
things together with an or statement to
check if only one of the conditions is
true but in this case we want to make
sure that users the owner and that they
have a verified email like I mentioned
before the request object has all kinds
of useful information in this case we're
going to look at the token on the auth
object that contains an email verified
property of true or false we can also
see when a user signed up if they're
anonymous if they have a phone number to
compose all kinds of other useful rules
but another common thing you'll need in
your rules is to know what the existing
data looks like as compared to the
incoming data to get the existing data
you can use the resource keyword
followed by data but try not to confuse
that with request resource data I
recommend writing functions as existing
data and incoming data just to make this
very explicit and clear
because these are easy to mix up and
it's really important that you don't
mess up your back-end rules so when
might you need existing data a common
use case would be if you have a certain
document that maybe gets locked after
it's published if we jump up to the
products path we can look at the
existing product document and we'll make
sure that it's not locked before running
the update checking existing data is
usually most important when your users
can control whether or not a document
should be modified at some point when it
comes to incoming data there's all kinds
of validation rules that we can apply to
our underlying data structure let's
imagine that our product document of
greater than $10 so if the user tries to
send an update where the price is less
than $10 we're going to cause this
update to fail so looking at the
incoming data is very important for
maintaining the integrity of your
database now switching gears in episode
75 I talked about rule-based user
authorization and I want to revisit some
of those concepts now in that lesson we
saved information about the user's role
on their user document and we need to
read that document when applying a rule
to various parts of the database this
documents not going to be available on
the user object so we're going to need a
different mechanism to read the document
whenever needed the rules environment
has a get keyword that will read a
document by pointing to a specific path
we need to use the absolute path so this
gets pretty verbose but if you put it
into a function then it's not too bad we
write out the path like normal and then
use dollar sign parentheses and
interpolate the request auth user ID
this gives us the current users document
and firestore which contains information
about their authorized roles now let's
use this function to authorize a user to
update a product we can read the
document and then we have an object of
roles so we can get all of the keys from
that object by calling keys on it then
has any will check if the user has any
of these authorized roles such as editor
or admin you can also use has all to
make sure that the user has all of these
roles at the end of the day that gives
you a very simple solution for
implementing rule-based user
authorization another
interesting thing to think about is how
time impacts your database security a
common scenario is to throttle the
amount of data that a user can create
during a certain duration of time we can
get the current time of any request by
just calling request time then there's a
duration helper that we can use to
operate on the time stamp for example we
want to make sure the request time comes
after the created at time stamp plus a
duration of 60 seconds in other words
the user can only write to a product
document every 60 seconds so duration
just allows you to add a number of
seconds minutes or hours and compare
them to a firestore timestamp I'm going
to go ahead and wrap up there hopefully
this helps you avoid becoming the next
major data breach victim if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you're ready to take things to the
next level consider becoming a pro
subscriber at angular firebase calm
you'll get a whole bunch of exclusive
content and direct access to chat with
me on slack thanks for watching and I'll
see you soon